the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
how are you guys doing recently there
was a religious debate on a channel
called Fresh and fit many of you will be
aware of it it's a channel usually which
discusses gender issues and now they'
ventured into something new and they had
two people from the Muslim side and two
people from the Christian SES had two
people who are very highly regarded from
the Muslim side danu who a a Harvard
graduate actually and trained in the
Islamic Sciences with an excellent
debating record and AZ the Trini who is
an expert in textual criticism as you
would have noticed in the debate itself
against two Christians one of them is a
philosopher his name is j Di and another
one his name is Sam who is a vile
despicable individual the like of which
I have never seen before online
especially Vis A V Muslims and Islam
just to give you a taste of this I will
let you see a video but before I do so
I'll Preamble it with this fact that
there was a person who was meant to be
in that debate that day who I also put
for forward his name is Jake the Muslim
metaphysician and this man has got an
undefeated record in debating a very
dangerous opponent a technically gifted
philosopher with an undergraduate and a
postgraduate in philosophy which is
completing the postgraduate and who is
trained in the Islamic Sciences I have
full faith in this man and of course
he's actually challenged
Sam in the past and Sam has denied
actually uh rejected this challenge due
to fear and trepidation but just to give
you a kind of a feeling of why we're
going to go a little bit hard on Sam
this man who his own close Inner Circle
people like Anthony Rogers his own close
friends close-knit friends have said
that he is a woman beater a predator
he's attacked his wife he's assaulted
his wife he's he's dangerous he's a
dangerous man he's a coward because he
attacked his wife here's a man who is a
known wife beater he abandoned his own
children
and he keeps doing it and now he's lost
them let's take a look at this man and
some some of the things he says and come
back and respond in kind get ready
ladies please his seven inches is better
than your 5 and a half inches that's how
she us
to but she would constantly berate me
you don't tell me I don't love you I'm
not attracted to you I'll Never Love You
you I'll never be attracted to you and I
feel like you forced me in this marriage
she destroys your
manhood and destroys any desire to want
to be intimate the first time she
committed adultery she commit adultery
with an Assyrian man he was in my house
doing the plumbing for for our
bathroom as you can see with wife beat
Sam how disgusting he is and his excuse
for why his wife left him is that his
male member was only five Ines now he
may argue five inches is the national
average in his country uh with his
countrymen and so on five according to
statistics but I'll tell you what I mean
uh she was dissatisfied of course she
would be and we were dissatisfied as an
audience with your performance Sam uh
when you went against Daniel and when
you went against AZ the triny it's not
that really it's the fact that you're
lacking not in this but in testicular
fortitude but I hope you'll summon the
courage to accept this man who is much
more qualified than you in fact you're a
high school dropout you're a high school
dropout you've got the one-inch wiener
you beat your wife and somehow you've
become somewhat of a popular figure
among some me some Christians of course
I'm not going to say all of them who
probably uh see a lot of themselves in
you
unsatisfactory individuals who want to
attack Islam and attack the symbols of
Islam but let's see if you can summon
the secular fortitude to go against Jake
the Muslim metaphysician he's waiting
for a response to your challenge and of
course the debate will be on something
foundational something like the Trinity
anded huh or do you need to be a
professional philosopher as you've
indicated in the past to defend the very
basics of your religion I am not ail
philosopher I'm not a philosopher but
I'm honest I'm not a philosopher so why
would you debate a non- philosopher on
the Trinity being logically coherent if
you do say that well you should know
that that is enough of an indication to
indicate that your religion is false it
requires professional philosophers you
need to use Jay Di and other
professional philosophers as human
shield uhuh human shield just like your
wife needed to use the plumber for her
own satisfaction you needed to use
J for the satis the intellectual
satisfaction of the the public instead
of that why don't you do a one-on-one
debate with Jake the Muslim
metaphysician H we hope that you will
return favorably with a good result I
know that you're not used to providing
those the prophet Muhammad s. wasam told
us that when the son of Adam dies all of
his Good Deeds are interrupted they are
finished except for three
things a continuous charity and a
beneficial knowledge and also a a
righteous offspring that makes Dua for
him your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a mid a
dawa Center and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do whenever someone
prays there whenever someone gives
shahada in the Masjid whenever someone
learn something in the Masid yes that
will be something that you will have on
your scale so give generously and Allah
will give you even more